[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
how're you guys doing okay I want to let
you know one of our regulars would like
to buy you around tequila shot shots
first thing I need to do is sign these
release forms yep that's not how the
tequila shot-shot works I need everyone
to put on electric dog collar red for
the ladies seriously I will electrocute
the out of you while you take the
shot when you finish begin barking once
everyone is barking I will stop shocking
you
all right that's great oh well good once
buy you another round yeah yeah they'll
really be shocked to know my dog roofied
all of them you might be unaware that I
have my own drink a lot of celebrities
do
there's the Arnold Palmer the Shirley
Temple the Eliza Dushku yeah
and now the Tosh tini what's the Tosh
tini I'll tell you it's when you open an
expensive bottle of water and
immediately pour half of it straight
down the drain now fill the bottle up
with tap water and gently shake serve it
at room temperature and garnish with a
twist of Lyman the active ingredient in
sprite now go to a bar and order a Tosh
tini tonight and please enjoy
responsibly
he drinks gravy deal with the Dan
the trams delicious with tits like those
who needs a job keep on living every day
like it's Thanksgiving
alright so that's an actual glass of
your urine
very fresh very fresh looks pretty dark
a little the warmth I feel warm it is
it's a nice temperature yes Paris and
you just drink your peat and finally
milk let's talk about it did you know
the milk you've been drinking is
disgusting and impure the folks at white
power milk calm think so they go beyond
pasturization to racial purification
they have a room filled with Aryan women
who do nothing but gargle milk spit it
into bottles and send it to you the
racist insane consumer well I did some
digging turns out that company is out of
business or maybe fake but I'm not
crying over it instead I picked up the
torch and sort of purifying milk myself
Thanks
[Music]
thanks a lot man
thank you
[Music]
you